let's talk now about 2024 Republican
presidential candidate Chris Christie
the reason I talk about Chris Christie
is not because all of a sudden I'm a
republican the reason I talk about Chris
Christie is not because I think he's
going to win the Republican nomination I
will get to that in a moment the reason
I talk about Chris Christie is because
the contrast between a republican who is
connected to the real world but whom I
disagree with on policy and the rest of
these clowns could not be a Starker
contrast today Chris Christie appeared
on Fox News a couple of days ago and it
is remarkable yes he's pounding Trump
he's going after Trump he's ridiculing
Trump he's saying things about Trump
that the rest of them aren't willing to
say but it is remarkable how different
his entire demeanor and approach is to
this Republican primary he's almost
certainly not going to win and we'll
talk about that in a moment but listen
to Christy say things that are not
controversial and say them in a way that
they all should be saying them but
nobody's willing to do it other than
Chris Christie but my view is he's let
us down didn't build the wall Mexico
didn't pay for it didn't repeal and
replace Obamacare like he said he would
Sam's gonna balance the budget he didn't
and you mentioned debates look we should
have debates and everyone should be at
the debates and folks should go to
chrisgrizzy.com donate and make sure I'm
on the stage
but Donald Trump should be on that stage
too if you want the Republican
nomination the Republican voters have
the right to see us right in those
cameras and have us compare and then let
them choose
um and and American people are good at
that and we did but they need all the
information and that's what we want to
give them the fact is if Paul don't put
my stock into the polling well what
would I put that's what it is today you
know you know what they ask you how they
ask those questions you've been called
by posters they say if the election were
held today well if the elects were held
today I'd be shocked because the first
election is not going to be in January
in Iowa January of 2024. we're six seven
months away from that now so let's run a
campaign I I don't think we crowned
Kings in America you got to work for it
and Donald Trump needs to work for this
nomination
do y'all become friends again does he
offer you a cabinet post again do y'all
clean this up I think it becomes the
nomination I don't think so I think you
know some of the some of the stuff he's
called me
um over the last few months um I don't
think that's going to happen and and
that's sad but it is the truth of the
matter and it's his doing but you're not
closing the door to voting for him no
I'm saying I can't support him I can't
you won't vote I can't support either
one of them okay not Biden or Trump
because they're not competent and
qualified to be president for different
reasons Joe Biden predominantly because
of his age and what we've seen on TV and
Donald Trump because I don't believe he
can win Lawrence you know when you're
under this much criminal scrutiny and
the conduct by the way that he's engaged
in taking those documents keeping them
in his home making sure that his own
lawyers didn't get to see all of them
not telling the truth to the justice
department when they wanted those
documents back and now saying that what
he was saying on a tape when he's waving
around document well I was lying then
well I think Mama Jones and I know my
mom would say the same thing you're
lying once I'm not going to believe the
other time too we need to have someone
who's honest direct and who can beat the
Democrats because I'm tired of losing
Chris all right so listen this is not
remarkable stuff what's remarkable is
how remarkable unremarkable stuff sounds
from Chris Christie because no one else
is willing to say this stuff now it's
not lost on me that I'm sure it's
extremely triggering for Trump to turn
on Fox News which at one point was
extremely friendly to him as Trump says
and now they allow other candidates to
express their views it's not even that
Fox News is no longer friendly to Trump
it's just other candidates have other
views and they think they're better than
Trump this is not about glorifying Chris
Christie as the moral whatever Christy
stood behind Trump literally and
metaphorically for years and went with
all of the stuff and now all of a sudden
he's willing to say these things but
still it is a good thing to meet Maga
where they are and many of them are
still watching Fox News and that's why
it is a great thing to have Chris
Christie saying these things it is not
good for Trump to have a guy capable of
coherent and provocative sound bites
attacking Trump it's not good for Trump
will it make a difference I I don't know
and this is where I get to okay I want
to have this conversation with you as
well
uh people write to me
and I see the comments and they say
David you loser Chris Christie's not
gonna win
I never said Chris Christie was going to
win I'm not supporting Chris Christie
it's almost like just because I
recognize that Chris Christie's the only
sane Republican running a normal
campaign I want him to win and therefore
if he loses you've defeated me I'm not
voting for any of these people but it is
crystal clear crystal clear that if you
said one of these Republicans is going
to be the next president it's not going
to be Biden who do you go with it is
obvious I go with Chris Christie now
some people will write in and say David
how are you defending Christy who's so
corrupt I'm not defending Christy what
I'm telling you is he's the only
candidate willing to tell the truth
about Trump who's not playing Coy who
isn't angling for either a VP slot or
Trump's Maga voters or whatever the case
may be now he's obviously not going to
win as a result Chris Christie went from
polling one percent to 2.5 percent now
he's down to 2.4 percent and an average
of recent polls 2.4 is not super strong
okay even if it's more than double where
you started so there does it's really an
indictment of Maga
that there is essentially no appetite no
appetite for just a normal Republican
who would do things they claim to like I
think Chris Christie would probably try
to lower the taxes of the people
Republicans try to lower taxes for and
you know he said he wanted the wall
built he's mad at Trump because Trump
didn't build the wall I mean it's like
he would more or less do the things I
thought Republicans wanted and he has no
chance it is an incredible indictment of
the modern Republican Party
are you tired of getting crushed in the
market or the volatility there is some
good news which is that treasury yields
are surging you can now get a whopping
five percent yield on treasury bills
that is higher than any high yield
savings account that I have seen but
buying U.S treasuries can be a
complicated process at least it used to
be that's where our sponsor public.com
comes in with public you can buy
treasury bills in seconds right from
your phone couldn't be easier plus
public will even automatically roll over
your Investments at maturity so you have
one less thing to think about take
another thing off your plate treasury
bills are government-backed securities
considered one of the safest Investments
out there and when you buy them through
public they are securely stored at the
Bank of New York Mellon which is the
largest custodian Bank in the world no
minimum hold periods no settlement
delays you have full access to your
funds whenever you need them put your
cash to work earn at five percent yield
by going to public.com Pacman don't miss
the opportunity the link is down below